l'expérience en tant que personne noire aux
États-Unis, la connaissance que le
simple fait de vivre ma vie pourrait
amener quelqu'un à téléphoner à la police au sujet de ma vie,
puis ces policiers me blessent, ce qui
crée beaucoup de stress.
de mon chemin, il y
a un personnage dans Les Simpsons Ned
Flanders Le bébé du dessin
animé des Simpsons, le dessin animé le plus ancien de tous les temps et il
est toujours très amical, très extraverti,
très salut, voisin
Oakley dokely et je me retrouve à
mettre un peu un personnage de Ned Flanders
juste  marcher dans mon propre
quartier pour qu'il soit très clair
que je ne suis PAS une menace, cela crée une
réponse chez beaucoup d'entre nous qui est de nous
minimiser et d'être moins que
nous-mêmes pour être moins ouvert et libre quoi
être moins libre et donc nous si  même si
la police n'est pas impliquée là-bas dans notre tête,
alors nous nous surveillons, il m'enregistre en train de me
menacer moi-même et mon chien
la raison pour laquelle les Blancs
se sentent si à l'aise de demander l'
application de la loi aux Noirs qui n'ont
enfreint aucune loi est parce que c'est ce que les
Blancs ont appris, c'est ce
que tous les Américains ont appris par une
longue histoire de mépris pour une
vie noire et donc c'est normalisé que  vous
allez abuser du système de répartition du 9-1-1
pour un différend mineur ou n'êtes qu'une
observation d'une
violation potentielle du code de barbecue au bord d'un lac, par
exemple, oui, faisons venir des hommes avec une arme à feu,
car les conséquences sont si rarement
visitées dans  mode mortelle sur l'
Amérique blanche elle-même, j'ai vu en fait une longue
file dans l'héritage des soi-disant
dames qui mentent que son imagination était
si limitée qu'elle ne pouvait pas concevoir
qu'une personne noire à Central Park
existe pour profiter de la nature avoir une petite
poche pleine de  des friandises pour chiot alors qu'il
vaquait à ses affaires est-ce que cela
montre à quel point la pauvreté de son
imagination et sa compréhension de la façon dont
la vie existe
malheureusement que la pauvreté de son
imagination est visitée à plusieurs reprises par les
non-blancs et en particulier les Afro-
Américains ce que tout le monde a été
accuser l'accusatrice de Central Park est
en fait cette tentative d'activer la
police en son nom afin qu'au minimum
au minimum sa victime soit non seulement
diabolisée, voire même détruite, sa
vie lui a été enlevée simplement parce qu'il l'a
trouvé désagréable dans un espace dans
endroit où elle croyait qu'il n'avait rien à
faire
[Musique]
pour voir Ahmad notre Barry et George Floyd
et Christian Cooper et Brianna Taylor
peuvent tous quatre incidents sur une période de trois semaines
attirer l'attention des médias, tous avec un
usage excessif de la force comme thème et
leur  la noirceur comme
dénominateur commun, c'est un rappel que cette
nation a du travail à faire et donc c'est d'
une certaine manière c'est juste un autre jour aux
États-Unis comme ce n'est en fait pas
spécial du tout et c'est déprimant
et c'est réel
[Musique]
vivre respirer dormir marcher
allongé dans sa maison Je suis assis dans
sa voiture assis sur sa propriété et
la leçon est qu'ils sont des violations des
droits et libertés des personnes de couleur, en
particulier des Afro-Américains,
jour après jour et leurs
droits sont violés  par ceux qui
pensent qu'ils n'ont tout simplement pas le
droit d'exister librement quand j'ai vu la
vidéo jouer, c'est la même chose à
bien des égards d'une vidéo de barbecue Becky,
il y a un niveau de confiance et
de droit de la part du  Amy
Cooper dans cette vidéo qui était vraiment
familière et vraiment dégoûtante, nous vivons
à cette époque où les vies noires comptent
et les histoires vidéo virales et il ne s'est tout simplement
pas passé un moment où vous
n'entendez pas l'histoire des flics
trop zélés avec  une personne noire ce
n'est pas un problème noir américain c'est un
problème américain et donc je veux que l'
Amérique blanche soit aussi offensée par ces
incidents que l'Amérique noire ne se contente pas d'
exprimer de la sympathie pour l'offense que les
Noirs ressentent
soi-même offensé en tant qu'Américain  et en tant qu'être humain